hey guys goodness I have a fitness app
you get to work out life with me and
other amazing trainers every single day
go on down appear on the App Store or go
to feel life calm and start your journey
to become hey guys welcome back to
another cooking episode with big boy
so if you have not seen our meal prep
video be sure to go and check it out on
the link right above here where he
prepped my meals for me and so today
what we're going to show you is how to
cook a really simple breakfast for your
loved ones you can do this over the
weekend it's a great weekend idea you
can't get your kids involved your you
know whoever involved because it's super
simple so today we're making a salmon
egg wrap
I remember the first time he made it for
me I loved it because this recipe is
extremely low in carbs and high in
protein so instead of using your regular
wrap use egg to wrap it up and the
ingredients you'll need are 8 eggs about
100 grams of cooked salmon of a cup of
mushroom one whole onion about half a
red bell pepper or even yellow bell
pepper a handful of rocket one whole
avocado as well as mixed hubs and black
pepper to season our food Niarchos Imola
can get back co-op and that's right in
the garage
hope on ice you hope that you use hopes
in unity one Mission Possible hopster
okay that is it
Jesus Oh magenta that's it that's how it
Shaunie uses a type than me oh thank you
98 in Kanpur okay so I'm going to prep
the bell pepper as well as the onions
sure you can Skype any kitchen yeah so
great you okay why does it always take
over my ruling because I'm I just like
it enough or small enough oh I'm holding
the knife too dangerous I just let him
cook everything I just eat mine versus
his lens yeah Allatoona
pastilla Chaka she shot Olivia Sonia to
evangelism time to Netaji autumn is a
very important we're gonna swap roles
what do I be the eggs and then you
finish out the bell pepper as well as
onions okay let me be the X 8x again his
portion is always three times my portion
hands so many eggs
Wow hello oh yeah
mixed herbs and spices and I'm going to
add a little bit into the beaten eggs
and continue to mix it up I'm going to
cook the ingredients to put inside the a
crab which will be the bell pepper
onions mushroom as well as salmon and
Terrence will be cooking the egg wrap
three ways a panda [ __ ] yum yum
you yeah he might be honest no let's go
right that's cooked let's go cook so I'm
using coconut oil and I'm gonna use
about half a tablespoon and just coat
the entire pan make sure is warm and now
start by cooking your onions of a half
of the onions cooking unto is nice and
golden brown and now we're going to add
the bell peppers
as well as the mushrooms so continue
cooking until all the ingredients are
cooked through especially your mushrooms
and just keep stirring I would say about
4 to 5 minutes and the final ingredient
I'll be adding is the cooked salmon yay
they're all right so I'm gonna add this
in to the mixture look at that this is
actually a huge portion so the salmon is
in make sure it's all broken into pieces
and just mix it together with all your
vegetables and then as always we're
going to season it with mixed herbs as
well as a little bit of black pepper
Wow Emilio do that
male heir so this is done and not
Terence is going to cook the egg wrap
and I'm just going to remove this from
the heat and let it cool down we got
that Mahima do that oh man oh that's all
right can I not say okay okay sorry
Johnny when John saw a trap which is
Thank You Man come home food off Oh what
did you find you okay so just a moment
you find you a meal for you there's over
time do that so yea foas okay give us
one [ __ ] sorry either okay say I'm
not eager touch it yet yeah Wow - some
more dude I grab ah thank you
oh yeah that's easier to put some wrong
either
so this is the mixture yes and we're
gonna add a little bit of rockets as
well and not forgetting some healthy
fats avocado like I can't do this man it
stresses me out because I know what's
gonna happen to my eggs it's just gonna
be scrambled eggs
EW gross we also love hot you table
Pataca yeah okay fighting G oo ki
Young's object yeah quite make sure any
our seesaw okay no Blair fun type of I
don't even start the engine without okay
me know after avocado juice what
now you go out you know the final title
highway and yeah the bareheaded okay
Danny Daniela so new Hannity done do us
on top what I we don't do topless is
hope yet okay are we not put the avocado
Oh perfect
don't forget to try this recipe out okay
okay social media job T bizarre yasoda
okay so he's actually wrapping the
Reiser yeah independent hi Giuliana
too greedy we put too much ingredients
okay yeah okay good you who attended a
while but needed want were young height
housing of hot a polio
so that's the first rap look at that not
perfect because we will bring too greedy
with the ingredients so yeah let's do it
a second time round two so the first
time we were being too greedy with the
ingredients and now second round let's
see how this goes I have faith in you
okay you have to go so slow man like
seriously this kind of dishes it's just
not my thing I would just rather make
scrambled eggs are you happy with that
yeah you broken a little bit but it's
okay we'll make sure the presentation is
spot-on all right yay
look at that mmm okay look at that
I like how the egg is still slightly
undercooked I like it like that slightly
gooey and not fully so you guys make up
to retire to Atia
she's a path choose or maybe pop I can
sort of tie together Amanda okay yes
right I'm gonna leave you to slice it
okay
tea Sydney out here kayo general see you
cancer woman biker chick I get your
final exam okay let's go with chili
flakes okay hopefully something will
come out there you go yeah so as you can
see this is a very high protein a crap
it doesn't look perfect you don't always
get a perfect but all the time but that
doesn't matter because it was made with
love by look delicious it is delicious
I love this man every time he makes this
for breakfast I love this even if it's
for lunch
you can also pack this out with you if
you want to usually I'll eat about half
the a crap so for my portion it's about
450 calories 20 grams of protein and
whatever I can finish and his portion
it goes in there somehow it's about 750
calories and yeah 40 No
30 35 grams of protein yeah so be sure
to try this out it is absolutely
delicious take pictures of your a crap
post tag me at your NASA official
because I want to see it and make sure
to make it for your loved ones as well
this is a great weekend practice idea
don't forget to subscribe to my youtube
channel
leave your comments below leave a what
strong emoji if you want to see more
videos of us together whether its recipe
whether it's work out let me know in the
comments below and we'll be filming
videos wow how it Silla house it's good
it's really moist creamy from the
avocado at the same time you get that
salmon tastes mixed together with a
mushroom
[Music]